as Brittany Greiner returns home
President Biden has vowed he will not
give up on another American in Russian
custody Paul Whelan a U.S marine veteran
was arrested and charged in 2018 with
Espionage he is currently serving a
16-year sentence in a Russian penal
colony Whelan has denied the Espionage
charges and in a phone call was seen in
yesterday Whelan said he is happy Griner
was released but disappointed that more
has not been done to secure his own
release we're joined Now by Paul's
sister that's Elizabeth Whelan Elizabeth
Whelan thank you so much for joining us
this morning
oh thank you so much for having me on
I would imagine it was a Bittersweet day
for your family yesterday the family
statement was very thoughtful and very
gracious but I'm wondering how you all
are processing that Brittany Greiner is
home and your brother is still in
custody
well it's uh I mean I'm not going to say
there weren't emotional moments when we
first heard the news but I think a
certain amount of resolve and
determination has taken over we need to
solve this problem not just for my
brother but also for Americans in
general who want to travel in a hostile
weak foreign Nations taking Americans
prisoner and holding them as hostages
this has to stop and my brother needs to
come home
and there's already some criticism about
this deal that you know the U.S made the
swap for a merchant of death a really as
some people say really terrible man
who's done terrible things for an NBA
WNBA basketball star that it's really
not a fair trade and your brother Still
Remains behind what do you say about the
politics that are now seeping into this
oh they really infuriate me to begin
with where have all those people been
for the last four years when my
brother's been held where were there
good ideas I hope they're sharing them
with the National Security Council as
far the way I look at it once a hostile
for our nation has taken an American
prisoner we need to do whatever it takes
to get them back and then we need to use
punishments and deterrence to stop it
from happening again so I welcome anyone
who wants to share their ideas uh they
can send them to me I'll pass them on
Elizabeth your brother yesterday said he
was disappointed that more were not
being done but I've heard you say you
think everything that can be done is
being done uh what are the next steps
given that impasse
well my brother Paul unfortunately we
can't tell him everything that's going
on obviously I can't uh I can't tell a
lot of people everything that's going on
it's really difficult this is a this is
not an easy thing to solve we have a
country Russia who is trying
purposefully to cause trouble over here
they weren't going to in my opinion send
both Paul and Brittany home at the same
time and give our president the win but
we need to figure out a way around that
I don't know exactly what that solution
is I constantly love crazy ideas at the
people who are in charge of that hoping
that some of my ideas will will spur
them onto action that will actually
result in Paul's release
Elizabeth you spoke with President Biden
yesterday on the phone what did you say
to him but more importantly did he say
anything to you that brought you some
comfort
um to a certain extent it was a
continuation of conversations I've had
both with him and and with uh the people
who work for him
um it I I don't look for apologies I
look for action and I am willing to be
very plain spoken uh about that we heard
the President yesterday say that Russia
is treating Paul's case differently uh
and they certainly are he's charged with
Espionage he had a jump drive they say
was State secrets in their view what do
you make of these charges which the US
says are illegitimate and improper that
Russia is leveling against your brother
oh there is a ridiculous as it comes and
this is a Russian fairy tale uh they
planted that USB drive on my brother and
then five minutes later arrested him for
quote unquote Espionage uh this is um a
story they have concocted and they're
trying to use
um they're trying to stick to the story
in order to get leverage over the U.S
they have treated Paul's case
differently
um differently from Trevor Reed uh and
definitely differently from Brittany's
uh it's a it's a definite problem does
the wheel and family have hope still
that the government will come through
for you
well we have to don't we I mean the
problem is that uh the foreign
governments who are taking Americans
like this they're not taking them
because of the specific person they're
taking them because they want to get
back in some way at the United States so
yes I do have hope the the folks right
now who've been working to first get um
you know Trevor and Paul back and then
trying to get Brittany and Paul back uh
they they are
going to all lengths to try to make that
happen but I do think for Paul you know
when I think of how he must feel
um how it must look to him not having
all the information that we do and
wondering why why was I left again why
did that you know why did it only work
for Brittany at the same time you know
I'm going to say again we are very
pleased to see Brittany come home any
wrongfully detained American that comes
back from overseas is a win for America
yeah and the Grinders say they're going
to work to keep the attention on Paul's
case as well they're with you and your
fight
yeah when I saw Charelle uh say that
yesterday that was I mean that was the
first emotional crack really to see that
support
yeah yeah they definitely are supporting
you thank you very much Elizabeth
wheelen the family letter as I said was
very thoughtful and very gracious we
thank you